nous sommes d'ailleurs étonnés face aux
menaces de sanctions pour non respect
des engagements l3313 la zone amie la
France est je le répète le pays le plus
fibré d'Europe il faut prendre le temps
de mesurer la prouesse industrielle et
technologique que cela représente en
seulement 5 ans entre 2017 et 2022 20
millions de locaux supplémentaires sont
devenus éligibles à la fibre c'est une
augmentation de 230% dans les
territoires les moins denses des réseaux
d'initiatives publiques 7 millions de
locaux supplémentaires sont devenus
éligibles à la fibre c'est une
augmentation de 717%. en fin depuis 2017
le Très Haut Débit compte 11 millions
d'abonnés supplémentaires pour atteindre
le chiffre de 17 millions soit plus de
la moitié du nombre total d'abonnements
à Internet en France l'effort est
collectif dont le partageons avec tous
les acteurs de la filière néanmoins avec
un investissement de près de 9 milliards
d'euros et plus de 80% des prises
déployées entre 2011 et 2017 orange et
le principal artisan de ce succès c'est
aussi orange qui consciente sa place au
sein de la filière a décidé le seul et
sans contrepartie de financer les
surcoûts de ses partenaires liés aux
règles sanitaires en temps de covid nous
avons augmenté la rémunération à l'acte
de nos partenaires jusque 30% et
concéder des avances de trésorerie à
hauteur de 375 millions d'euros pour la
seule année 2020 ce choix a permis de
maintenir le rythme des déploiements au
pire de la crise et avec 6 millions de
prises FTTH déployées 2020 a même été
une année record nous aurions pourtant
pu faire un tout autre choix celui de
nous délier sur le plan juridique de nos
obligations réglementaires et de nos
engagements à la faveur de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire nous avons fait le
choix strictement inverse celui de
maintenir les déploiements quoi qu'il en
coûte aujourd'hui encore nous continuons
de protéger financièrement nos
partenaires en augmentant la
rémunération de ceux qui interviennent
sur les réseaux en considération de
l'inflation toutes ces raisons et ces
chiffres expliquent ma surprise
lorsqu'on m'a informé de menaces de nous
sanctionner pour des retards de
déploiement à léguer prenons le temps de
nous comparer à nos voisins en Allemagne
au Royaume-Uni la pénétration de la
fibre n'atteint pas 30% en France elle
est de plus de 80% même si nous étions
en retard sur nos engagements ce que
nous contestons de quelques dizaines de
milliers de prises seraient juste
raisonnable ou encore utile de
sanctionner l'opérateur qui a fait de la
France le pays le plus fibré d'Europe